munich in the middle of the day and
inside the tent of one of munich's
biggest Brewers is a non-stop party
the job of this woman who's wearing
traditional attire is to keep the party
going and make sure festivities don't
get out of hand I'm really excited I
always look forward to the start of the
oktoberfest but I'm also a bit scared in
case something goes wrong i modified the
pull of the tent the more stress you
have and when the tent is closed due to
overcrowding and there's no air that
goes in or out that stress is certainly
a factor
but tough situations are nothing new for
Stephanie fendler she's 46 and a 14-year
veteran of the Munich Beer Festival I
bring into the job and got used to
conditions having the responsibility and
of course being in charge Stephanie
friendless father is Viggle Hagen the
longest-serving festival 10 posts he
took over the Louvin brought into 1979
these days he's primarily involved in
the management and paperwork the actual
action on the ground is run by his
daughter he's proud to see Stephanie
fendler maintaining the tradition yes
since the hoopla keys organized has a
friendly manner and she knows her jobs
associates of it thank you quences can
you save it again for Stephanie
preparations for each year's festival
begin early in the new year when the
first reservation start coming in in the
afternoons people can sit wherever they
want in the evening almost all tables
are booked in advance war since move you
do we sit where basically everyone sits
where they've always sat if that's what
makes the festival so lovely what's the
reasons or sea mud
she gives regular guests special
personal attention that includes tables
that are passed on from one generation
of the same family to the next she's
known many customers for years that's
also part of the festival phenomenon
it's a mass attendance event but at the
same time it's got a very personal feel
aside from the regulars Stephanie
fendler always gives extra time and
space for special guests I'm em I'd
evidence I'd be up on what we once had
Prince our barrack moniker here I went
to see if his royal highness was doing
okay he was standing on a bench wearing
this funny hat and was dancing so I
thought he's a regular kind of guy time
for a team talk in total stephanie has
270 waitresses working for her and they
all know the job at hand a woman is a
woman regardless right Stephie Stephie
we're one big gaggle of girls
and it's not just the ladies stephanie
gives orders to the leader of the brass
band likewise takes his cues from her
you know if we have a pretty precise
concept we know what the score is by now
stop we can make dude I blinking we are
well behaved in the afternoon later on
we get better at least once a day the
band plays Amazing Grace the boss's
favorite song it's at quieter moments
like this when Stephanie fendler can
look ahead to when all the commotion is
over for another year on the one hand
i'm glad to be able to return to
normality I've got the chance to have
five minutes to myself
on the other hand it's like falling into
a hole because all the action does rub
off on you right now she certainly got
her hands full as do most guests about
8,000 of them at one time in one of
munich's most popular via tents
you